Hey hello rejects its Greg Albert here
with the lovely and talented Syd Wilder
Syd Wilder I mean I did a reaction to
one of her videos Thanksgiving your new
stepmom thank you yes she's seriously
hysterical like I watched a few of her
videos before you to watch that one I
really like the one you do it Flula
thank you what's your name what's your
name I was hysterical you're like really
funny you're really funny you can follow
her on Instagram but I feel like if some
just goes to your Instagram then I got
she's just a pretty girl or something
she's just doing if you like go to her
channel or the Syd Wilder channel on
channel so no channel I'm telling you
yeah very go Chyna great sketches on
there you know my own Borat you're on
one of the videos that's been requested
today is a video the kind of videos I
don't ever really do but I've gotten so
many requests and for some reason
whenever I do these every like six
months they become like one of the
biggest videos on the channel I try not
to laugh challenge video try not to
laugh read my favorite laughing my
favorite funny animal fails do you like
animals
oh my gosh I hope you like em we'll get
one really cute doggy ensued well it's
not mine it's like half mine but yeah
he's yeah on the back a back yeah - yes
we can clean up after her I'm doing my
best to remain calm and confident as I'm
sitting next to her such a good I think
I'm doing an okay job you're doing a
great job so you have to be serious
alright yeah don't laugh you can't don't
you can't grin you know you're not
allowed don't smile
oh I got this deadpan look I naturally
smile Casino we're using natural
lighting so if the lighting keeps
switching it's cuz the weather's
behaving funky he's trying to be very
fancy but I'm trying visas pro mm-hmm
please stash I was taking the bear
[Music]
Oh
I kinda do squads like that and here we
have the no headed camel a rare camel
with no hat
what's okay okay okay that's me that's
just adorable guys mild dog has ambition
I just love it he's a bulldog
[Music]
we're done
that cat census okay
advocate dogs look dead knodel is it or
Joe Gunn I don't care Sibley nice run i
speech he's not biting I'll give you a
free the try not
Oh then German Shepherds like now Oh
oh [ __ ] that's leaves me with women I
was like that's 2016-17 that's my guy
yeah that's a guy oh oh my gosh that's
hysterical
[Music]
oh my gosh this why are cats funnier
these cats think he can do more I know
Oh
Oh what's going on here oh my gosh mom I
was crazy haha
those are funny too movie dog well what
is that a corgi either go cord okay oh
that dog [ __ ] guy keeps things I mean
he really good evening again
I wonder if I would look like that
sometimes what is that I wish I knew oh
oh my gosh I love and in Wills react to
TV
I miss my cats right now oh my gosh I
know I miss mine too
[Music]
wow that's impressive
oh my gosh they're really freaky that
sounds like it looks like a nightmare
this is cute huh that was me growing up
I was the worst Oh
did not do that all records I have them
by my area we have coyotes but they're
both equally bad what's like a Star Wars
kid
[Music]
Wow I think you heard Stevie Wonder
taking a move at a Syd Wilder there oh
look I can died you into shock do you
teach Babs to do that
Oh oh my gosh
bad cats into doors the bed that's ready
whoa that was impressive that was good
[Music]
come on that's me when I'm right don't
tell me I'm wrong did you forget I'm not
supposed to laugh I know I think it's
just just turning your yeah I should say
yeah this is a reaction now just a
regular video that's impressive
how how's it impressive that's a lot
oh that's a lot I couldn't have a dogs
makes great news like Barry I think it's
a fairy Michelle where do you live
where's Michelle live that is so cute I
can't leave at 7:00 Oh what people would
catch that fish that's so mean
[Music]
bird people though oh hey recover well
oh there it is this is the battery
screen me at 50 no whoa that'll be you
at 15
oh no no no dad huh that's amazing that
seemed like it was a great plan
Wow memo's Davis most they said yeah dot
people dogs that big though you're like
horses speaking speaking of Wow horse
exercise well the second Oh laughter oh
whoa what the hell is going on is that a
spaceship that would think we what just
happened
Oh scared
hello McKenzie that
oh I think we both laugh they get safe
to say we failed the challenge pretty
early on nail'd sorry i walked over a
lot of it thank you
no don't worry about no one's talking
here that was some pretty funny stuff
you don't know any cats do you I did a
hard cat oh you did what happened break
up yeah I'm gonna keep up are you gonna
keep him I gotta keep mine in my break
up oh hey guys always gonna keep the
cats well you know I signed for it when
we got the cats did you really yeah vase
we said that if we broke up I would keep
the cats see I wasn't thinking that far
ahead
yeah you know it's like I don't wanna
think about that but now you gotta
prepare yeah you have to prepare prepare
I should have thought about that but it
was a replacement one he like already
had what was just a replacement guide so
you I was like oh we should get a cat we
had pets your whole life I've lost a lot
of my animals
no not like as they died just cause like
literally they just vanished like oh
your responsibilities no no I asked my
mom and I think she lied a lot cuz she
was a single mom so she couldn't like
keep up with everything yeah I think she
ended up giving him two other homes but
she would just like they did they ran
away but they really run away
[Music]
I heard dogs release oxytocin which
makes you more bonded to the pet and
that's why dogs are so healthy for you
could add ten years to your life
Oh helps reduce the risk of heart
disease - seriously oh I have it I guess
I have this Babs she's like when I need
her yeah she's it's a lot I have a
career justify Hugh terrier design shut
it definitely looks like she is no
keeping fake hair is like my pet right
now okay thank you
yeah this this whole weave you should
have seen I had I have so much hair it's
like a pet a pet it doesn't wash beep
over to me without the oxygen I never
try to weave on do you want to you're
doing one day that we ah I'll go get you
awake you really would do that yeah wow
you went with the blond one I get to go
you see you guys please Khaleesi
like run up the stairs lazy like Game of
Thrones Khaleesi yeah we're this week
for my halloween costume let's see what
were you Khaleesi for Halloween no I was
I met the same thing every year I'm not
one of those girls cuz I I do so many
characters all year that it's like my
Halloween comes I assume to be simple I
just want to do the same character ever
daddy bad hair for the rest of the other
video see this is the thumbnail photo
right yeah this is a Khaleesi look you
look half Khaleesi half Drogo sort of
situation I took my life wait what are
they called again the cow cow cow half a
Targaryen tart yeah that's who I look
like the Jesus Christ they used to have
in like nineteen cylinders now super
blonde what this is a great look I think
I think this is amazing now I feel like
women will chase me you know oh my god I
feel like if I look like this I wouldn't
have to try to get women maybe just come
out it will this is gonna be a true
Instagram profile photo bumble tinder
whatever the hell people use what else
they use there's a swarm thing bumble
tinder once a grinder plus grinder plus
finder plus grinder which they're always
looking for men like me I think I didn't
mean action hero with this you could be
anything look he's an adventure this is
a new Avenger character you guys Oh
could you imagine like hey hey do your
girl voice he said my girl voice it
sounds like a gay guy do a girl voice
I'm just thinking huh you're not you're
not a gay guy whoa not again whoa I am
mind blown right now
don't say whoa you sound like an actual
dude no I don't don't say that yeah that
doesn't make you subscribe
nobody right now when you go to SIDS
[Music]
stop it do you feel better wait wait I
don't feel as masculine I feel like I
had an atonement way I feel like you
look beautiful I feel like that they
like shave off all my hair to have me
walk through the streets naked and a
shame no you don't need to feel that way
because that's not healthy and she had a
body double so no she didn't she did did
she
I thought she did I don't know I don't
know I saw her face sometimes right oh
he did a way that by double look great I
know look great I know Sid was the body
double yeah follow her on Instagram this
is how you plug this is how you promote
people right here
this is nothing to do with the video
reacted to you for the last 10 minutes
no no but it's interesting
subscribe to see Wilders channel follow
her on Instagram and she check out her
sketches seriously check out her
sketches it's an awesome really I'm not
just saying that they're genuinely
really voting spiritual and she also has
are you doing mini sketches or something
on your Instagram to you right like if
you like exclusive content ideas for
your Instagram yeah you got to check it
out think I'm not on her all the time
it's not the top of my screen then look
out brace you're gonna be in it thank
you
actually I'm writing right now are you I
may be sure I'm right in three months
well I did it I have to let you know
we're writing it I'm doing this I know
sorry sorry excellent with my hands full
of accents and impressions yeah alright
guys we're gonna move on to something
better
mm-hmm what is it let's find out what
could be better